listos para el 55 en la unión europea
ese fue el anuncio de la presidenta de
la comisión
úrsula von der leyen quien presentó el
plan para reducir las emisiones de gases
desde 1990 en al menos un 55 por ciento
para la década de 2030
europa es ahora el primer continente que
presenta una estrategia integral para
cumplir con las ambiciones climáticas
además del objetivo ahora tenemos la
hoja de ruta para llegar allí
jeter
entre las doce medidas propuestas
destaca la prohibición de fabricación de
automóviles con combustibles fósiles
desde 2035 y el aumento del costo de la
emisión de carbono para calefacción
transporte y fabricación se grabará el
combustible de aviación con alto
contenido de carbono y se cobrará a los
importadores en la frontera por el
carbono emitido en la fabricación de
productos como cemento acero y aluminio
en el exterior medidas ambiciosas que
requieren del respaldo de los 27 estados
miembros y que reconocen que van a ser
complicadas de implementar este plan va
a ser realmente difícil lo sé pero es
algo que tenemos que hacer es nuestra
responsabilidad se teme la oposición de
empresas estados miembros pobres y de
los países más contaminantes el rechazo
se debe al alto coste de la transición
que puede aumentar el coste de vida
afectando a los más vulnerables para
ello la unión europea prepara un fondo
social de más de 70 mil millones de
euros que trate de evitar una respuesta
como la de los chalecos amarillos en
francia además ha insistido a los
estados a aprovechar los fondos
operación para impulsar la economía
verde inversiones que quieren acompañar
de pedagogía con la que demostrar que la
transición es justa y necesaria